bonsoir 18h35 ce soir rue copernic un
16ème arrondissement de paris une
voiture sur laquelle a été posée demande
explose devant une synagogue c'est un
attentat raciste antisémite
il a fait pour l'instant quatre morts et
deux blessés dont sept graves 1 serait
dans le com on voir les premières images
qui ont été tournées
après cette attente voici oui cette
mairie se trouvait donc dans la rep a
permis qu en face de la synagogue et un
petit peu avant l'attentât
on l'a vu deux jeunes gens s'approchait
de cette voiture de jeunes gens qui
circulaient en moto il avait un paquet
avec eux et c'est ce pack est
semble-t-il qui expédie un paquet qui
devait contenir plusieurs kilos
d'explosifs comme on est loin de la
violence de la déflagration
en effet dans un rayon de plus de saint
jacques dans cette rue copernic une rue
assez étroites et passante qui va des la
place victor hugo à l'avenue kléber
c'est à dire donc très des changes
l'euro est bien sûr dans un rayon donc
de plus de 150 mètres tout leur être des
immeubles étaient soufflées toutes les
devantures des magasins et pour et la
sté les secours sont arrivés très vite
plusieurs drames voitures de pompiers et
des ambulances vous voyez par ailleurs
des épaves de vacquières dunkerque ont
été projetés à plus de 30 mètres de
l'endroit des lieux l'explosion